Today, thanks to what you have gained here, you leave Liberty with conviction and confidence as your armor.
You know what you believe.
You know who you are.
And you know whom you will serve.
Not all colleges instill that kind of confidence but it will be among the most prized qualities from your education here.
Moral certainty, clear standards and a commitment to spiritual ideals will set you apart in a world that is searching for meaning.
You enter a world with civilizations and economies that are far from equal.
Harvard University historian David Landes devoted his lifelong study to understanding why some civilizations rise...
...and why others falter.
His conclusion was this: culture makes all the difference.
Not natural resources, not geography, but what people believe and what they value.
The power of these values, this culture, is evidenced by a recent Brookings Institution study...
...that Senator Rick Santorum brought to my attention.
For those who graduate from high school, get a job and marry before they have their first child,...
...the probability that they will be poor is two percent.
But if those things are absent, 76% will be poor.
Culture. What you believe, what you value, how you live, matters.
People of different faiths, like yours and mine, sometimes wonder where we can meet in common purpose...
...when there are so many differences in creed and theology.
Surely the answer is that we can meet in service,...
...in shared moral convictions about our nation, stemming from a common worldview.
The best case for this is always the example of Christian men and women working and witnessing to carry God's love into every life,...
...people like the late Chuck Colson.
Not long ago, Chuck recounted a story from his days just after leaving prison.
He was assured by people of influence that, even with his prison record,...
...a man with his connections and experience could still live very comfortably.
They'd make some calls, get Chuck situated, set him up once again as an important man.
His choice at that crossroads would make him instead, a great man.
The call to service is one of the fundamental elements of our national character and culture.
It has motivated every great movement of conscience that this hopeful, fair-minded country of ours has ever seen.
Sometimes, as Dr. Viktor Frankl observed in his book for the ages,...
...it's not a matter of what we're asking of life, but rather what life is asking of us.
How often the answer to our own problems is to help others with theirs.
You've all learned a thing or two about these gifts and the good purposes they can serve.
They are yours to have and yours to share.
Sometimes your Liberty education will set you apart and always it will help direct your path.
And as you now leave, and make for new places near and far,...
...I hope for each one of you that your path will be long and life will be kind.
The ideals that brought you here, the wisdom you gained here and the friends you found here,...
...may these blessings be with you always, wherever you go.
Thank you all. God bless you. And God bless the United States of America.